اوكرانيا تورط مسؤولا امريكيا مع روسيا هو
تمثال بسيف ليزر يثير جدلا في الجزائر
ونجوم يصدرون اغاني خاصه احتفالا بزفاف
ولي العهد الاردني اهلا بكم
من الحزب الجمهوري معروف بدعمه لاوكرانيا
ودفاعه بقوه عن زياده المساعدات العسكريه
لاوكرانيا في مواجهه روسيا والجمعه زار
السنه ابراهام اوكرانيا
للمره الثالثه من وقت بدايه الحرب لكن هذه
المره الجدل حول هذه الزياره كان اكثر من
اي مره والسبب مقطع نشرته الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه بعد اللقاء اللي جمع الرئيس
الاوكراني بالسنتر الامريكيه
جيد وفي مجمل رده رد تحديدا على رئيس مجلس
الامن الروسي اللي وصفوه بالاحمق وقال له
انه لو تبغى توقف موت الروس واوقف الحرب
لكن الحقيقه انه لا انت ولا بوتين سائلين
عن الجلود الروس بعد كل هذا شفنا مفاجاه
فالرئاسه الاوكرانيه فجاه نزلت فيديو تاني
للقاء كاملا والفيديو بيظهر انه الجملتين
اللي قال لهم السنه ما كانوا ورا بعض ولا
كانوا اصلا في نفس السياق
صناعه
[موسيقى]
تامر
نعم
رغم الفيديو اللي نزل واللي وضح انه
ورق بعض لكن الهجوم الروسي ما وقف لا بل
تصعد والداخليه الروسيه اعلنت وضع
السيناتور الامريكي على قوائم المطلوبين
وقالت انها فتحت تحقيق جنائي حول
التصريحات لكن ما وضحت ايش الجريمه اللي
بيشتبه انه ارتكبها طيب ينضم الينا من كيف
الصحفي محمد البابا اهلا فيك معنا محمد
طبعا يعني
الموضوع كان شويه غريب لانه اول شيء نزل
الفيديو بعدين رجع نزل فيديو تاني طيب
الفيديو الاول هل نقدر نقول انه في انطباع
انه كان متعمد انه يتمنتج بهذه الطريقه او
لا يعني
بالحقيقه يعني اول شيء الرئيس الاوكراني
وفريق عمله وخاصه فريق الاعلام اللي جنبه
هم من خلفيه اعلاميه ويعلمون كيفيه
استخدام جميع الفرص لاعطاء كدعايه ودعم
لاوكرانيا وعاده عندما يكون هناك ضيوف عند
الرئيس الاوكراني
بيصدر متل بيانات او مقتطفات من اللقاءات
مع المسؤولين يعني الزوار
لكسر ماريانكا او للاداره الرئاسيه او حتى
للرئيس الاوكراني ولكن يعني تحديدا كيفيه
يعني المونتاج وما حصل في هذا التسجيل هو
يثير الريبه خاصه يعني تم اختيار الكلمات
الاقصى عندما تحدث انه يجب يعني رشا
والداي او الروس سيموتون هو الترجمه
الصحيحه
يعني الروس سيموتون جاء ضمن سياق خاصه
يعني قبل الزياره بيوم كان هناك استهداف
مستشفى في اوكرانيا وانا استوضحت يعني مع
يعني مع مقربين من الاداره الرئاسيه حول
طبيعه كيفيه انشاء او كيفيه الحديث يعني
كان في استياء ليله الزياره انه كان في
استهداف لاحدى المستشفيات في مدينه
ضحايا وبلال الجلسه اللي بعيده كانت التي
لم تكن مسجله في البدايه بعض الاحاديث
الجانبيه كان يتحدثون عن هذا الوضع وكان
الطرفان الرئيس الاوكراني وحتى يعني
السيناتور اللينسي يتحدثون بقساوه لان
يعني كان هناك جريمه كبيره هزه الراي
العام الاوكراني ولكن ما خرج في هذا
التسجيل يعني يثير الريبه خاصه كيفيه يعني
المونتاج الذي يعني
ظهر في البدايه ان يدعو ان الان يدعو او
يقول ان يعني الولايات المتحده تقدم الدعم
ليموت الروس هنا يعني البرتغندا الروسيه
كما تصف في اوكرانيا استغلت هذه النقطه
لاشعال الراي العام الروسي ان
روسيا هي مع الامريكان الذين يمولون
اوكرانيا بالمال والسلاح لقتل
تحدث عن هذا الموضوع وقال انه بالفعل
اشتغلت
الروسيه ولكن لما تتحدث محمد عن
انه تقول انه الفيديو طريقه تمنتجته تثير
الريبه يعني نقدر نقول انه فعلا الرئيس
الاوكراني يعني كان حابب انه حابب انه
يسبب ازمه بين امريكا وروسيا حابب يزيدها
شعر
يعني عاده
الاوكرانيين يريدون حشد الدعم من الجميع
ضد روسيا الجانب الاوكراني يحاول استغلال
فرصه ليكون هناك دعم لاوكرانيا لمواجهه
روسيا حتى في الرياضه التي هي بعيده عن
السياسه كان الرئيس الاوكراني يعني وقت
كاس العالم كان الرئيس الاوكراني يريد
القاء كلمه يعني شد الانصار والحصول على
دعم وتاييد لاوكرانيا بوجه روسيا ويعني
هذا حقه يعني شخص للحصول على الدعم ولكن
ونفس الشيء
صحيح صحيح اي فرصه يعني يحاول الرئيس
الاوكراني وفي طريقه الحصول واستغلال جميع
الفرص
لابراست سوره اوكرانيا لشد تعاطف ولو
بالقوه يمكنك للحشد التعاطف والدعم ليش
اعادوا نشر الفيديو كاملا غير ممنتج هل
يكون هذا بسبب مثلا طلب من السنه اللينز
يغراهام ويعني ايش يكون الموضوع وهل
الفيديو الجديد الكامل حصد نفس الاهتمام
اللي حصده الفيديو الاول
في اوكرانيا نعم حاصل في اوكرانيا والدول
الغربيات يعني بالبدايه الدوائر الامريكيه
تعمل ضمن الاسطل والقوانين لذلك يعني كان
المفروض على الجانب الاوكراني توضيح يعني
خلفيه تصريحات لانه ربما ستكون هناك
مسائلات من الخارجيه الامريكيه او داخل
يعني السلطات الامريكيه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لهذا لهذا السيناتور حول طبيعه
التصحيح وكيف جاء لذلك الجانب الاوكراني
اخلاقيا كان عليه ان ينشر كامل التسجيل
لايضاح للراي العام كيفيه او او في او
سياق الحديث الذي حصل الجانب الاوكراني
خرج منتصرا يعني ضمن الحمله او
البروباجندر الروسيه التي تجيش الراي
العام الروسي هناك حمله اخرى
تثبت دائما ان الروس يراهنون على
المعلومات وعلى المواضيع الخاطئه وهذا ما
يستغل هذه الطريقه يلي عم تستغلها ايضا
الاوكرانيين لابراز ان روسيا تريد اشعال
وتحميل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
مسؤوليه الحرب
هي انطباعات خلق انطباعات من الطرفين طيب
الان لما الجانب الروسي يطلع ويقول انه
وضع السنه الامريكي على قوائم المطلوبين
قديش هذه الخطوه فعلا يعني كبيره او مهمه
يعني اولا السيناتور لن يقوم بزياره
امريكا لسياره روسيا لانه يعني يرفض
النظام الروسي ويرفض تصرفات الاداره
البوتينيه كما توصف في اوكرانيا لذلك هي
لا تؤثر هذه عقوبات مثل اي عقوبات التي
فرضت من اوكرانيا على بوتين ايضا يعني هي
هي عقوبات شكليه وليس لها او يعني
يكون لها تاثير حتى يعني عندما يكون الغرض
باي عقوبات او منع سفر مثلا لمسؤولين روس
هذا يؤثر على رؤوس ولكن الروس لا يستطيعون
فرض اي تاثيرات اللي منع سفر مثلا او له
احتجاز او اعتقال اي شخص خارج عن سيطره
روسيا او خارج يعني نف وز روسيا يعني اكيد
يعني ما حيروح يقضي عندهم اي اجازه قريبا
طيب نحن بنشكرك على هذه التوضيحات كان
معنا من كيف الصحفي محمد البابا شكرا لك
محمد
[موسيقى]
اهلا من جديد في الجزائر في جدل مالي
الدنيا هناك سبب تمثال اعلنت السلطات عنهم
التمثال هو للامير عبد القادر الجزائري
اللي بيعتبر من مؤسسي الدوله الجزائريه
الحديثه وقائد مقاومتها ضد الاستعمار
الفرنسي وبيلقب بافضل عدو لفرنسا طيب
الاعلان عن مشروع التمثال العملاق كان من
كم يوم على لسان والي وهران
120 مليار
قال اخدموا
الامير عبد القادر في الجبل تاع
نهار الخميس دارو لنا
[تصفيق]
مميزاتها التمثال هذا انه عنده السيف
نتاعه والسيف دونك
تكون متوجهه القبل للمصلين
[تصفيق]
والحصان يكون عنده صرف
رمزا للاركان الخمسه للاسلام
ويكون اعلى من السلطه
[تصفيق]
مثل ما سمعت والي وهران اعلن عن التمثال
العملاق اللي ناويين يكون اكبر من اكبر
تمثال في العالم حاليا واللي هو تمثال
المسيح في
البرازيل فقال انه تمثال راح يشيد فوق
اعلى قمه في الجزائر وراح يكون ارتفاعه 42
متر وراح يكون كمان التمثال حامل سيف في
ليزر باتجاه القبله وسيشيد على خمسه ركائز
في اشاره لاركان الاسلام الخمسه الجزئيه
اللي استرعت انتباه الناس واثارت الجدل
فيما يخص التمثال مكان كل اللي قلناه يعني
مع انه يعني في كثير اشياء تستوقف الواحد
في ولكن والي وهران قال انه التكلفه حتكون
مليار و200 مليون دينار جزائري يعني
تقريبا 9 مليون دولار وقالوا ان الفلوس
انصرفت رسميا للمشروع وهنا الجزائريين
انقسموا الناس شايفه انه تمثال تكريمي مثل
هذا للامير عبد القادر شيء جميل وضروري
وناس تانيه شايفه انه لا تبذير للاموال
ماله داعي ابدا وانه الملايين هذه المفروض
كانت تنحط في مشاريع خدميه للمواطنين وهذا
الشيء كان حيكون افضل للبلد ككل
الذكاء الاصطناعي عنوان بنسمع كل يوم
بخصوص التقدم متطور سريع لجالس بيصير في
هذا المجال ولكن في الفتره الاخيره كثره
الاصوات اللي بتحذر منه وخاصه من قاده
التكنولوجيا وبحثين يوم بعد يوم بيزيد
تخوفهم من نمو الذكاء الاصطناعي وخطورته
على الانسان لكن لمن ينضم لهذه الاصوات
عراب الذكاء الاصطناعي جفري اللي كان
لابحاثه دور كبير في الوصول الى
عنده جوائز كبيره جدا في مجال الذكاء
الصناعي من بينها جائزه الانجاز مدى
الحياه هنا لازم ناخذ وقفه الصراحه يعني
فجفري هو احد رواد الذكاء الاصطناعي وكان
بيعمل في شركه جوجل ولكن استقال من اسابيع
اقيل حسب تقارير انه سبب استقالته هو
مخاوفه المتصاعده من اضرار الذكاء
الاصطناعي على البشر ومن وقت استقالته ما
توقف عن الكلام عن خطوره الذكاء الاصطناعي
وندمه وانه اشتغل لسنوات كثيره فيه وقلقوا
من انه يحل الذكاء الاصطناعي محل البشر
الجديد انه خلال مقابله له مع شبكه البي
ار كمل جفري وجهه نظره عن خطوره الذكاء
الاصطناعي وخلينا نسمع سواء اشكال
انا
قرب الذكاء الاصطناعي بيقول انه ممكن يصير
اذكى من البشر لكن هذا ما كان اكثر شيء
يخوف في كلامه اللي يخوف في كلامه هو
كلامه تحديدا اللي قاله وبنسمعوا لاول مره
عن تهديد وجودي على البشريه وخطوره من
الذكاء الاصطناعي بتشبه خطوره الاسلحه
النوويه
حد قاسم بيبي
[موسيقى]
تحضيرات للزفاف الملكي في الاردن مستمره
وثلاثه ايام بتفصلنا عن الحدث اللي مستحود
على اهتمام الناس اليوم في استاد عمان في
حفل ضخم ومجاني بيجمع النجوم تامر حسني هو
راغب علامه واحمد سعد والفنان الاردنيتين
ديانا كرزون وزين عوض واخبر وصول او صور
وصول الفنانين لعمان ملت المنصات في حفل
ثاني كمان اعلن عنه يوم 3 يونيو وهذا
حيكون حبل جماهيري ومجاني كمان للفنان
حسين الجسمي واهداء هو من دوله الامارات
وعلى فكره التسجيل للحفله بعد الاعلان عنه
نفذ خلال 15 دقيقه غير الحفلات الفنانين
راغب على مواليد توفيق وملحم زين اعلنوا
عن طرح اغاني خاصه للاحتفال بالزفاف
الناس تصلي على النبي الهاشمي
والزغاريد اتعلم يا قمر حزيران
لنور كل مكان
ليله ست العواصم
اتزينت
واميرك المحبوب امير نشمي مغيوب هذا ابن
هواشم هذا امير الاردن بالحب ولا اقوى
بالفرح نجوم وعم تضوى فرح الحسين ورجوه
الاردن
فرحان ومن اعز جبين سيدنا
ولمعت عيني
ملكتنا عما نعرسنا عزمتنا جينا
يا عمان ويا امير اللي ما حدا قدك ابن
الاشرف بنيه ودنيا
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا احنا وصلنا الختام حلقه اليوم
انا اعود القاكم غدا ان شاء الله في حلقه
جديده من تفاعلكم في امان الله